Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de frases 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Julieth riaño
[Música]
Aunque México ha evitado convertirse en
un tercer país seguro para la acogida de
migrantes la realidad es que ahora
recibe a quienes son deportados desde
Estados Unidos como resultado del
reciente acuerdo dirigido a los
venezolanos así entonces México no es ni
el país de destino ni el país de origen
pero sí uno en el que los migrantes
deben permanecer sin que sea claro bajo
qué condición las deportaciones de
venezolanos ya comenzaron y las ciudades
fronterizas mexicanas reciben a los que
son devueltos Luis Muñoz nos cuenta lo
que pasa en la frontera sur de Estados
Unidos
Robert José fue deportado desde Estados
Unidos pero no volverá a Venezuela lo
han dejado en México
todos los ahorros que tenía nosotros
tenemos pasando un mes y medio viajando
y lo que teníamos ya ya se ha gastado ya
ya lo que queda es poco y uno se va para
allá entonces lo devuelve entonces
perdemos al perdemos todo ya yo tengo
aquí ya tres días tres días aquí en
México pasando frío hambre después de
transitar durante semanas por Sudamérica
y Centroamérica el dinero se ha acabado
no encuentran alternativas
la mayoría de los migrantes son
venezolanos viajan en familia algunas
han quedado separadas por el muro
porque lo ves por una pantalla y no es
lo que yo quiera yo quiero irlo abrazar
decirle papi Te extraño te quiero darle
un beso es muy difícil pero pese a las
dificultades muchos venezolanos siguen
llegando lo viven con frustración y
organizan manifestaciones espontáneas Y
entonces cuando llegamos aquí muchos que
vienen venir vienen en camino pues ahí
fue donde nos enteramos de que esto nos
cerraron las puertas por completo y me
parece que ha sido una violación a los
Derechos Humanos porque antes de eso
tiene que haber un preaviso Estados
Unidos llegó a un acuerdo para deportar
migrantes venezolanos a México lo hizo
bajo la regla título 42 que niega la
posibilidad de solicitar asilor un
recurso de la Administración Trump en
medio de la emergencia por Kobe 19
Estados Unidos permitirá la entrada de
24.000 venezolanos por vía aérea sin
embargo más de 150.000 venezolanos han
sido atrapados cruzando la frontera en
el último año
el objetivo principal del acuerdo
migratorio México Estados Unidos es
disuadir los cruces por la frontera
terrestre y según los datos ese objetivo
pareciera estar cumpliéndose tras los
primeros días de su entrada en vigor la
patrulla fronteriza de Estados Unidos
informó una disminución en más del 80%
de los encuentros de venezolanos en sus
fronteras pero el tránsito por
Centroamérica avanza y ni la advertencia
de deportación ni los peligros del
camino los convencen de detenerse en su
viaje al norte
el destino Estados Unidos el camino
miles de kilómetros y riesgos de todo
tipo muchos venezolanos dejan atrás su
país pero también hay los que han estado
ahorrando por todo América Latina y se
marchan al norte arriesgando su vida
el peligro más mediático es la selva del
Darién una trampa mortal que los
migrantes deben cruzar desde Colombia a
Panamá para pasar a Centroamérica un
ejercicio físico durísimo que puede
durar más de una semana
muerta hasta allá
el sacrificio de subir sobre el lodo que
se le hunde a uno las piernas para sacar
la rodilla bajar
es una pesadilla sin fin
Pero también en el resto de la ruta por
Centroamérica los migrantes se ponen en
manos de las mafias y grupos organizados
donde pierden sus derechos y se exponen
a violencias físicas y sexuales tienes
miedo Todo el tiempo te meten un chico
terror que te van a violar gracias a
Dios a mí no me pasó nada pero todo es
que te van a violar te van a matar te
van a violar te van a matar y siempre
estás con eso y dejar sola una mujer no
es horrible También tienen que cruzar
distintos países donde se encuentran con
políticas migratorias restrictivas que
provocan la represión policial a los
niños
diciendo que yo no le tiro piedra no
hago nada yo lo mío es pasivo lo que
quiero resolver el problema de mi
familia el negocio hace que las mafias
quieran sacar la máxima rentabilidad por
lo que sus vidas están en peligro desde
el momento en el que van hacinados en
camiones y hasta en accidentes de
tráfico que hacemos nosotros que no
podemos quedarnos pegados ahí Tenemos
que salir para adelante Entonces nos
vamos por los caminos verdes Por los
caminos peligrosos que ellos quieren que
nosotros no lo tomemos pero que en
realidad nos hacen tomar la fuerza
Estados Unidos argumenta que con las
deportaciones a México buscan evitar que
los migrantes queden en manos de la
mafia Entonces el mensaje grande
que queremos dar es que primeramente no
deberían migrantes llegar
a estos corredores
que son organizados por los delincuentes
por los criminales sin embargo miles de
venezolanos buscan el prometido sueño
americano En definitiva una mejor vida
las dudas sobre el futuro de los
migrantes que viajan rumbo a Estados
Unidos incluso desde antes del 12 de
octubre fecha de implementación del
acuerdo son múltiples el papel de México
es uno de los que más genera preguntas
una de ellas sobre si el país está
preparado para gestionar las
deportaciones desde Estados Unidos
incluso con sus ciudades fronterizas a
tope hasta que inmigrantes de France 24
los invitamos a comentar en nuestras
redes sociales con el hashtag migrantes
f24 sigan con más información en France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]